I'm laughing at the idea of scottish specific oh no if I find out you're cheating senpai
I'll kick you in your fukin ct
Wait, do you guys actually want yandere scottish more like a solo? I'll do it if I find out you're fucking cheating senpai
I'll kick your fucking cunt in I would have to whisper it so fast though be like
Should I do that like the fastest whisper really yandere scottish ASMR to muster?
Later
I thought I was the only love of your life
What do you mean you didn't like my accent?
What do you mean that you don't find it intimidating?
Are you not scared of me?
Are you no fear of what I'm gonna do to you if I catch you with another girl?
Aye, that's what I'm for
So sit down senpai and take it like a good boy